it's like don't come out there and talk
about Game Pass numbers nothing don't
come out there and talk about no numbers
I don't want to see no numbers on that
board I don't want to see how many Xbox
but how many how many bugs are grounded
with squished no no I I want to see
games games and games and I think that
at this point you got to show up or just
stay home shut up um stay home oh don't
even come outside yeah well just like
you did don't come out until you do
don't come out until you here's the
thing like last year was what was it I
would say it was like a horrible year
but if you were just on Xbox it was a
rough year and it's just like you got to
make up for that man you gotta show that
star field
um you know I honestly feel like inside
Xbox is okay they just they need to
restructure it to where the interviews
is at the end of it you know they come
out they they go over what's going on
they show gameplay and they say if you
want to see more in-depth interviews